welcome matters video this is your bird
yeah and now by now he is hidden his
flag okay honey okay it's not not
important or anything but it's funny
that he's changing the flag all the time
and now he's got it on hidden okay No
close to fifty percent against him
always so having interesting games so we
got an English opening with c-45
basically
okay so probably is doing this and I
wonder if you like it feels like i had
this on the board once okay let's do
this do this retreat I remember that
there are very funny tricks with e4 like
92 i play a form that's quite quite nice
because those nights are somewhat
uncoordinated goo okay do I go see six
year yeah probably I should do this some
point and Bishop 685 in the long run
I is going for that so you see intending
to play some sort of peace sacrifice or
did you just overlooked it okay I'm just
going to do this it's really funny if a
night captures as f5 and he loses one of
the nights very very cute tactic I once
fell into this into a tournament game
with white and there was really stunned
that this is possible the the big idea
is that now the position has opened up
and this is something that is usually
good for the bishop for the bishops rook
a3 maybe yeah maybe activate this
okay let's trade it i wonder if i should
play Bishop f5 yeah maybe trying to
provoke your form now okay for its not
going to play I guess I'm not sure about
goobie three now that I think of it this
is really a good idea I don't know ok
let's attack the pawn
let's take this pawn for the sea doing
now 23 maybe it's not the kind of guy
who wants to go back but maybe or maybe
you can go 94 in this position to take
on c6 after Bishop takes e4 possible I
have a time advantage wow it's not
happening that often he's going back now
I don't really want to draw is that
something is as something I can do like
take on b5 and stuff like that one queen
bee six is the sum of Quincy seven ok
let's just see that I want to continue
this I don't want it wrong he probably
wouldn't have accepted any way or
somehow deviated from the repetition but
not sure if this is really a correct
yeah this kind of decision but I didn't
didn't want to wander draw now maybe I
have night f5 or nine f5 knight c6 not
good
I was thinking that I can maybe get in
d5 but I underestimated 94 really i can
get the bishop to a six and threaten
threaten with d5 that's that's actually
interesting Quincy eight maybe keeping
this this all this going this Bishop on
a six so d5 yeah t5 interesting
okay um should I take let's take twice I
don't think the bishop on a six is so
particularly well placed and now i have
c-5m using the the pin on the diagonal
this this is a piece come on buddy this
is just the place resign yes this is an
even score okay yeah the games against
him always interesting always
interesting so chair not sure what I
mean okay he didn't he didn't see form
which is which is a really funny move
from it's not like fatal but I think
something that definitely helps like
getting my my bishop open yeah it's
really useful to see this once there the
Knights arm stuck to each other here
this night does not have a square at all
and this is hanging of course yeah so
got this not sure if this really was
good but okay I definitely should have
an okay position here nothing brilliant
but okay and yeah there's this fields
very very logical in a way now aged 50
sorry this was too much yeah I wonder
after this Bishop a6 idea Here I am okay
the computer I am I can light a force
the the engine suggestion this makes
lots of sense here Knight b6 possible
and after this this also this move funny
interesting 9 a-4 is very unnatural
looking move yeah you went here and now
after d 5 i'm just bet I am
the position s is really not good yeah
this is c5 idea it says is stronger here
he had wins apiece and also I'm just
threatening to just grab the podium
let's say he plays something like that
note that the pawn also hangs I can take
take and go here even with the night
capturing job yeah that was a pretty
decent game I think I mean um before is
a very very nice motif okay thanks for
watching